Uh, as David mentioned, my name's Justin Kagan.
I am the VP of revenue integrity
operational compliance for a company called Arrivia.
It's really a fancy way of saying that anything
that deals with revenue, I stick my nose into
and kind of piss everybody else off.
Uh, I'm also a certified fraud examiner
through the ACFE.
And that's just again, another fiancecy way of saying
that I love fraud and I've been
trained in how to detect fraud.
Um, and I will start off by saying, yes,
that is my quote up there.
And so a little bit about me,
when I was younger, when kids wanted to be
police officers, firefighters,
doctors, whatever.
I wanted to be a criminal.
It, it was exciting, right? Like it was,
it seemed like it was fun. And the reason being,
and it goes with uh my little picture there,
so I fell in love with this movie called Hudson Hawk.
It's a movie with Bruce Willis in it,
very campy, cheesy movie,
but Bruce Willis plays an art thief in
the, the movie.
And he just gets released from jail and he gets suckered
back into
Doing another heist,
uh, once he gets back out and it's just
a lot of campy zany fun
and as a child seeing that I was like that looks
really cool. I like art.
He's an art thief,
therefore I should,
this seems like it should be fun to do,
um.
But as I grew up,
you know, everybody told me
crime doesn't pay.
Which I feel like that might be a lie
now. Uh, it seems like, you know, the more
notorious you are, you get movies, you
get documentaries, you get to be on
Dancing with the Stars,
uh, all sorts of fun things that, you know, you
wouldn't normally
expect for criminals to be able to get,
um.
But that kind of led what led me through my journey though.
So as I continued to, to get older and everything, I
took forensic science, you know, eventually wanted to
be a forensic scientist and work with law enforcement.
That didn't pan out the way I wanted it to.
I moved into the, the private sector and
started with my company Arria. I originally started on the phones
and then moved into the revenue integrity department
from there.
And for me that was kind of my calling.
At that point, you know,
yeah, I wasn't a criminal,
but now I was moving into a realm where I could think like
a criminal, act like a criminal,
get paid to do it, and not get in trouble
for it.
So, no downside.
So a little bit about Olivia.
And so we're a white label travel agency. We've been
around for about
twenty-ish plus years.
I I originally started out in the timeshare space
where if you owned a timeshare, you'd be able to trade in your
timeshare week,
and we would give you a cruise to go on a, a
nice fantastic cruise, uh, vacation.
Since then, you know, it's expanded, we moved into
being a, a full-blown travel agency
offering air, car, car, hotel, resorts,
uh,
everything that you can imagine under the sun as far as like vacation goes.
And from there
Kind of a good example of it, we moved into the, the loyalty
space. And
one of our partners, Spirit, so
we actually just brought them on super excited about that.
And what we do for them is we allow them to use
your loyalty points,
right? That you get from, you know, spending using your
spirit card.
When you book travel, you come into our platform.
I forgot what I was gonna say. Sorry. Um, so
you come into our platform.
And react as a merchant of record
and since we have, you know, over 2100 employees
globally,
that opens us up to a lot of different
levels of risk, right?
This allows, you know,
one of our employees could potentially, you know, use your credit
card information.
They could use your loyalty points to book their own vacations.
Unfortunately, yes, it does happen, but that's
why I exist, right, to catch these guys.
And with that, we have to kind of understand the fraud
and to be able to catch these guys, we really need to understand like how
do they think?
How do they move? What do they do? What, how are they gonna act?
Long time ago
A bunch of fraud fighters came up with what's called the fraud
triangle, and they broke it down into three components
of why fraud exists, why fraud
happens.
First one is being in the opportunity.
So is the opportunity present there for somebody
to be able to commit fraud
and that could just be, you know, maybe nobody's watching.
Or it could be maybe
you accidentally
did something and realized that
nobody caught it and so therefore, you continue
to do it on so on and so forth.
So that's where the opportunity comes in.
Motive
Motive by far is the easiest one.
Most motives is driven by
some type of monetary gain.
Right. Either
in, in our case,
a free vacation because you don't have enough money
to be able to,
to pay for your own vacation.
Uh, maybe you're gonna sell something, which I'll talk
about here in a, a little bit.
But there's some, there's always some kind of drive to it
like nobody just, you know, suddenly wakes up and says, I'm
gonna commit fraud just because, right? There's
always something there to it.
Lastly is the rationalization of it.
And this is actually kind of the, the most
interesting part. Um.
I don't know
if too many people are aware of, um,
a guy used to be called Tipper X.
He did an insider trading, uh, fraud
scheme.
Uh, way back when,
but I got to listen to him talk. And one of the things that he said is,
He rationalized his fraud
by saying it was a victimless crime,
right? There was no victim in this.
And I really paid attention to that.
And as I've interviewed some of the people at our company
that we've identified the internal fraud with,
you know, I, I asked them, you know, why did you guys do it?
And a lot of times they say the same thing.
We felt like it was gonna be victimless,
right? The, the company has enough money to cover this,
you know, if we use a customer's benefits,
the company's gonna pay for that like it's gonna go
back to them. They're not out anything.
But there's to us there is no victim.
Other times we do hear the whole piece of
well it's owed to me,
you know, I, I work really hard. I
feel underappreciated at my company,
so
I'm rationalizing me doing this action
because
I feel like it's owed to me by the company.
So
Getting into the meat and potatoes of everything, like how do we
get connected with Terra Mind?
So we're actually doing an investigation.
That was actually completely separate for the reason why we actually
linked up with Terramine.
Uh, so we're going through an investigation where we noticed
that there had been some fraudulent hotel bookings made
on a bunch of members' accounts.
And as we're going through it,
we're looking through everything that we're going into our CRM
and looking at, you know, the actions that have taken place in the
CRM
we noticed that.
A couple of agents' names are on.
Changes within the accounts like they were changing the
names that were on the accounts or changing phone numbers or
changing email addresses.
They're changing a bunch of information to kind of hide
what they were doing.
So we brought those folks in and said, hey, listen,
like, So the members are
called in, they say they don't recognize the people that have made these
bookings.
They didn't use the points.
What's going on? Why is your name all over these accounts?
First thing they said was, well,
we shared our passwords with other people,
which I mean, if you're in IT or cybersecurity,
that's a huge no no, right? Like you don't
share your credentials with anybody.
And so we obviously, we told them they're like,
hey, like what are you doing? Like you can't share your
credentials. Like that's just,
why would you do that? Now look what's happened.
Even though you shared your credentials and you're saying it's
not you, you're still responsible because it's under your
name. As they heard
that, well,
they do like, you know, most thieves do, you know, no
honor amongst thieves. They started throwing everybody under
the bus.
It was this person. It was that person.
This person did it over here. Yes, I might have done
this one, but they're the ones that told me how to do this.
It was just left and right.
But they did throw out one name that seemed to be really
interesting, and so we started digging into that person.
And as we're looking into it.
We noticed that this individual had a high number
of views on accounts.
All right, so we're going through, you know, some of our
information from the, the data warehouse and everything to, to
pull this up and we're like,
Man, why does she have almost
10 times, 20 times most other
agents for views on accounts?
Like this doesn't make sense.
And
keep in mind,
she got thrown into the mix because of this hotel
booking piece.
As we're looking at it, we're also noticing there's
no hotel bookings. There's no
any travel booked on these accounts.
What is going on? Like, why?
And as we continue to go through it and continue to dig
through it, We
started assuming why
this was going on.
But we couldn't really prove it.
And what we assumed was going on
was that this person was building lead lists,
and they were going to then sell these lead lists
to another party.
I will say this was in our, our Mexico
office. And
one thing that Mexico is known for is
cartels.
And what we've learned is
What the cartels were actually doing down in Mexico
is they would approach
some of the timeshares down there, call centers down
there. They would approach employees
and offering them cash to build
lead lists for them.
And typically every lead, like lead
that they had, they would give, you know, maybe 50 cents,
right? Maybe $1 for like every lead that
they got. But
then they would call these leads, the cartel folks would call
these leads.
And this is actually um
Found this out through the FBI that
This is actually one of the top ways that cartels
make money currently,
is by doing this scam where
they call out to you and say, hey,
If you want to get out of your timeshare, we're gonna buy it for you.
We'll pay you $100,000 150,000
dollars to sell your timeshare to us.
You're free of it. You don't have to worry about it
anymore. And
you get to make some money.
That sounds like a good deal, right?
I mean, a lot of these people probably purchased their timeshares around
like $50,000 maybe $60,000
right? So they're coming out way ahead.
So they're like, yeah, you know,
I do, I want to do it. I want to do that.
And then what they say is, well,
There is a fee for this. Think of it like a closing
cost fee, like when you're buying a house, right?
So there's a fee for this. Usually they start about like $5000.
And
So you say, OK, that's fine, right?
You know, I'm fine with paying that. You're gonna give me 100,000.
You know, sometimes they'd even sweeten it up and say, you know, we'll
give you that 5000 back.
You know, so instead of getting 100,000, you're gonna get 105,000
back. So yeah, you're like,
all right, cool. I'll, I'll give you that $5000.
A couple of weeks goes down the road,
you hear back from him again, hey, there were some issues, you
know, with the government.
There are some additional fees to this.
We need more money.
And they keep doing this cycle
until that person finally says,
all right, I have no more money or I'm
now realizing that this is a scam.
Usually it's done over wire, so it's not as very easy to
be like, hey, I'm just gonna charge this back.
Like once that money's gone, it's gone,
right? So
That timeshare owner now very upset,
understandably, right? I mean, they just got bilked out of
thousands of dollars. They got nothing
for it. So they're
very upset
So what does the cartel cartel do then?
They circle back to that person.
And they say, hey,
we found your information. There was a, a scam
call center that was raided.
Your information was in there.
We're gonna help you get it back.
And he used to be like, hey, yeah, I want my money back.
Like, whatever you gotta do. And they're pretty sophisticated
with this.
They create
fake IDs like fake lawyer IDs and
everything. They have fake government documents.
They have fake telephone numbers that if you
call up, like they'll answer, you know, this is illegal,
so and so, blah, blah, blah.
But they go through all that with you and like you get really excited.
OK, I'm gonna get my money back. I'm, I'm gonna get some kind
of justice.
And then they hit you with a
Well, there's a, there's a government fee for this.
So now you got to pay us more money.
So they're just going through these people and just cycling
back and, and going through and going through and going through and just
like getting more and more money, right?
And so that's what our fear was with this
person. Going through all of
these accounts.
But we had no way to really truly prove it, right?
We just had conjecture. Like all, all we could think
of was like,
yeah, we assume that you're doing it and you know what
they say about assuming, right?
So all we could do is assume.
Now in Mexico,
they have very different labor laws.
You can't just terminate somebody without cause.
Like, even though we felt we had cause, but if we couldn't prove
it, that's technically without cause.
And if we were to term them,
we either have to pay out a very heavy severance
or they could potentially turn around and sue us,
and then we would end up paying out a lot of money.
So the last thing that we wanna do is pay a fraudster
money to get them out of our system, right?
Um.
And so we're just like, OK, we can't do that, and we're just
like this says, you know, hitting a wall. No, we were banging our
heads against the wall trying to figure out like how
do we do this, right?
Cause there was a lot of accounts that this person
was going through.
We're really trying to figure it out. So we reached out to our cybersecurity
department and our IT department,
which, by the way, if I have any cybersecurity folks
in here or IT folks.
If you guys have a CFE at your company or
internal auditors,
I highly encourage you guys to actually get with them
and meet with them because that synergy
between both groups can actually do like a
whole lot of good damage within the company to actually
prevent insider threat.
But we reached out to them and we do work with them quite,
quite closely.
And we're asking them, you know, can you guys pull us down all the
team's messages? We need, you know,
this person's
Outlook inbox. We need you to pull
their OneDrive.
Which that part was gonna be a nightmare. I don't know if anybody's
ever had to sift through hundreds of Excel
documents
to look through data and find hidden data
and all that stuff. It's terrible
and it takes forever.
Um
And so we weren't really looking forward to that, but we
needed the information.
Downside was,
this was going to take time.
Right, like this wasn't gonna be a quick thing. It was
probably gonna take at least 2 weeks to get the data.
Probably another week to go
through it all and sift through it all and get, find the evidence
that we actually need
and then go and interview the person
again to show them all the, the information.
By that time, this lead list could be gone,
right? And we're talking this is a large lead list, not
something we'd want to get out.
So we're just like, all right, like how do, how can we speed this up?
How can we speed this up?
And this is where we got introduced to terramine.
We had one of our guys who worked in our workforce management
department. And he
came to us and we'd reached out to him on during this
investigation for much for some other stuff.
And he came to us and said, hey, like,
I heard you guys are a little bit stuck.
We're piloting this program.
It's called TerraMind.
And it's a soft, it's a
computer monitoring software.
Like, would you guys be interested in taking a look at it?
Like, yes, yes, we would.
And so
they brought us into the loop on this, but they gave us one
caveat.
They said,
We only have this on 20 people.
So we have 2100 employees.
They're only doing this on 20 people, and we need to
find one person.
Our odds were very, very low.
But
We struck gold.
That one person who had been on there, that one person
was part of the pilot.
So once we got access to the tool, that was the first thing we looked
for, like, is this person here? We're like, yes,
we have it.
And then we started digging into the tool.
And I'm not kidding when I say, like,
this was literally like having God mode in a video game.
We could see everything that this person was
doing on their computer.
We're looking at different times where
She probably had her child on there and it was like they
were playing Roblox,
watching Disney movies, things like that. We're
like, and we can see all this like
we're playing as a like as it's
our own screen, right?
On top of that, we have all the other data in there.
So we can identify
every single application, every
single website,
how long they were on the website for.
And we started piecing all those together and we started looking at
when they were accessing the CRM.
You know, a lot of the access was after hours,
which was, again, you know, one of our first clues that
something nefarious was going on.
And we started going in there, and we're able to actually sit
there and watch this employee.
Go into the account.
Sit there for a few seconds.
Copy the, the PII information,
go into Excel and paste it into Excel.
And we watched them do this multiple
times.
We actually got to see this employee also get a little
bit trickier too,
which would have made my life so much more difficult if
I had to go through all these Excel files.
She would not only copy and paste it into there,
she would change the font to white.
So that way it looked like nothing was in any of the cells.
And then she would hide the tab.
The likelihood of us finding that right
away, very slim.
Like we would obviously notice that the Excel file has a
large like file size,
so there's gotta be some kind of data there.
But to dig through that.
I actually find that off of the OneDrive.
would have taken forever.
You know, I'm very confident in my skills. I, I do a pretty
good job. But that would have taken me forever
if I didn't have this, right?
So this also helped us with our, our IT
department, right? Cause now we knew what Excel
file it was.
So now we can say, hey, we need these files. Don't
give me the whole hard drive.
Just give me these files.
So what would it take in, you know,
3 to 4 weeks to fully investigate
and handle with the, the employee?
Now it took us about 2 days to do.
Thankfully,
With this, we're actually able to stop
the file from even being sent out.
We're actually able to go back and see when she first
started. So the time that we
got rid of her.
And we're able to identify that the file never
got sent out. So we're actually able to
protect the data.
Which was for us, that's a game changer, right?
From a, a fraud perspective, being able to see
this information
is major.
Like David said, you know,
right at the beginning, you know, 83% of companies
are going to
experience some type of internal threat.
The majority of that when you're talking about fraud,
either doesn't get caught.
Or
gets caught months down the road,
usually by accident.
Right? It's usually because
your consumer called in.
And said he was upset because something, you know, happened
on their account,
or somebody else, you know, came across it
by accident.
So now we're moving into a completely different realm,
being able to actually see these screens.
Now we're getting into a realm where we can actually go in
and be more proactive about
preventing fraud, preventing,
protecting our data,
and keeping our systems more secure.
So what we did is once we saw this
information, And we realized how
powerful it was
and I look at everything that we could see. Like I said,
you can see applications, you can see the websites, we
can see IP information,
uh, really cool, my favorite functionality
OCR so we can actually
put things into a search and we can see if it popped
up on their screen at all.
So that
takes some of our investigations down
drastically.
Also helps with link analysis. We can stick like
a, a member ID into there
and we see all the different employees that maybe
have accessed that account. Maybe they didn't actually go into
the account. But it appeared
somewhere on the screen, either through an Excel file.
Um,
they accessed the front portion of the
account without actually going into it.
They were talking about it within a team's message.
So now we can see that and we can start grouping together like
anybody that may have access to the account. So if fraud
did occur,
now we can see everybody that may potentially
be involved.
So with that we, we took that on we said,
you know what, they're, they're piloting this and they've been,
you know, I think probably like 6 or 7
months already in the works of, of doing this we're
like, nope, we need this now.
So we took it over
and within about another 6 months we scaled it up to
1500 employees.
Now, why 1500 when we have 2100?
One of the key reasons being
Different laws and different geos
like Portugal,
you can't monitor somebody's computer 24/7.
So we have to continuously rotate them, them
in and out. So there's no sense in buying licenses
to
Have there for somebody that we're not monitoring, right?
But we continue to build that out.
Now, for us, yeah, again.
World's greatest tool, right?
Like I said, we can see everything.
But that does come with challenges.
Right, not everybody's gonna want to adopt that.
Now for our department we reported up
in through the sales organization which
was a very weird
organizational structure for for us tore through sales
but that's the way that we reported so
that wasn't that big of a push on that side but going into
the corporate world.
And on the corporate side of everything.
Became a little bit harder,
right? Because not everybody wanted
to be monitored, you know, everybody had that sense of,
OK, Big Brother is going to be watching us.
You know, now we're gonna get micromanaged,
yada yada yada.
So we really had to work to overcome that.
And some of the other concerns were, you know,
if I'm in marketing.
And so if I'm in the SLT for marketing,
I don't want
somebody from development looking at my people.
Or if I have 2 managers, I don't want
1 manager
being able to see the other manager's department, then they start bickering
back and forth at each other because the other person's
employees aren't doing what they're supposed to be doing.
So we had to go in and to
Set it up in such a way that
Everybody could only see their people,
right? So we had to alleviate that
concern. The
other concerns that started coming up were.
HIPAA and PCI compliance issues,
right? Cause we're now we're, we're monitoring the computer.
How many of you, you know, do like your
healthcare and stuff like that on your work computer?
I know I do because it's the easiest and it's tied to my,
my work email, right?
So we had to worry about that. So we'll block out
email. PCI, you know,
will block out payment screens.
And so we had to do a, a lot to really
kind of build that trust with everybody that
we're not gonna be looking at sensitive information.
We're not gonna be using that, that information in any
sort of shape or form.
We also created a, a governance
committee. To also kind
of help manage this.
So when we do investigations.
We'll have to go to this government governance committee.
And say, hey,
we need to move this person to what we call special
projects. And what that does
is now again, like I said, we, we're blocking
out payment screens, we're blocking out
email, we're moving in the special projects and
that kind of opens it up for us during our
investigation so we can see what's going on in those,
those realms.
Number one, that helps us not bug IT
to go pull down Outlook and Teams messages
and all that stuff.
But it also gives us just a full scope within
one system to be able to do it.
But we have to go through this governance committee, which
again helps kind of build that trust with
everybody. We also
communicate out to the company, you know, and I'm
sure a lot of your companies do this as well.
We'll let you know that your
computer is being monitored.
Now, we don't necessarily tell you exactly the full scope of how
it's being monitored, but it's being monitored.
So with all that, that kinda helped alleviate
some of the grumblings. I mean they're still there and they're
always gonna be there again because nobody wants to be monitored
and stuff like that.
But once we started really digging through it and going through it and
explaining it to people and then what the full capabilities
were, people really started to uh
to adopt that.
And some of those other pieces were, you know, positive
use cases.
Again, for me, yeah, I use it for fraud.
90% of my use of this tool is going to
be for some kind of negative reason because somebody's
doing something they shouldn't be doing
and now I need to go after them for, you
know, whatever it is that they're doing.
But as we went through this, we did start noticing
a lot of positive use cases for this.
One of those use cases being like for productivity.
One of the real strong ones that we
still continue to, to use today and, and
go through is
helping with our service levels.
We started noticing when we went in there that agents
would be key pressing,
right? It's, it's a fake kind of being active
and.
Whatever, keeping their computers awake.
And we started noticing this like quite a bit. Now
we did have some people doing it for nefarious reasons
because they were trying to avoid work
and you know we, we handled that. But the other
thing that we noticed is we had a lot of
employees that were just pressing on keys.
Because they didn't have enough calls. They didn't have enough
work. And
you know they'd be 2030, 40
minutes in between calls.
But then we look at some of the other departments
and they were just back to back calls,
you know, sometimes 10 minute wait times, 20
minute wait times.
And so what we started doing
The apartments that had, you know, the lower call volumes,
like in their mind, they're like, OK, we're overstaffed.
So we're gonna start reducing heads.
And we were looking, I was like, well, no, like, don't do
that. Let's reskill these individuals
to go into like these heavier call volume
areas.
And so that was like one of the big, you know, use cases
right there because not only did
that give employees the ability to
number one, not be bored,
give them the ability to sell more which
improved their commissions, right?
Which from my side that reduces the risk of
those employees committing fraud because now they're making more
money. Helped our service
levels.
With the, as far as the the calls went, which
put us in a better position with our brand partners.
So we were using it, you know, to kind of
go through some of that.
The other things that we would use it for is like we look at
some of our top producers
and we have one in in particular and
this guy is like an absolute beast when it
comes to sales like he's been like the top guy
for I don't even know how many years running
like nobody's been able to to outsell this guy
like he's always been the top.
But nobody really understood how he did it.
So we actually started watching him and we took the,
his video screen through Terramine,
and we matched that up to his calls.
Now this guy was very methodical.
He always said the exact same thing, exact same
jokes.
All the way through his calls, every single call, the exact
same, and it worked.
But we also when we start looking at the screen in
TerraMind,
we started noticing his patterns within
as he's actually moving through our applications
we would notice that
he would always go into the application
before he actually needed to get into it.
He already knew what he was gonna say so he can move very
quickly through it.
And we started looking at, you know, some of the lower performers,
and what we noticed is
a lot of them as they were going through their calls.
They'd be trying to pull up the application.
As they needed it instead of beforehand.
So and as we know with technology,
sometimes it's not the quickest thing in the world, especially
when it's web-based.
So we have these lower performers trying to pull something
up and while it's loading,
They don't know how to fill that silence.
Right, so they're just a lots of ums and
ah or just dead silence,
which I mean, in a, in a sales world
that's gonna kill
your sales call,
right? Like you don't want silence in there. You wanna be able
to continuously interacting.
So we identified that and we started building SOPs
on how to navigate through calls
and how to
Be more productive in your sales calls.
Flipping kind of back to the fraud side,
some of the positive use cases that we've been using for
this, we've also used it to
prove people innocent.
We actually had one case where
Uh one of our members called in.
They had just purchased a membership through us, a travel
membership. Shortly
after that purchase,
his credit card, credit card got used at a
Target. So he
called in saying, I've never used this credit
card except for with you guys.
Now it's been used at Target.
Your employee took my credit card information.
So we're actually able to go through.
And what we did is, again, we pulled up the phone
calls. We
pulled up Terrain.
Matched the screen up to the call.
First thing that we did is we looked at when the payment
information was taken.
So on the call, we can hear,
or I shouldn't say we can hear cause we, we do block that out for PCI
as well. But we know exactly when he's
giving the credit card information. We know how long it usually
takes somebody to give a credit card.
Matched it up to the screen.
And when as we walked to the screen, we could see him.
Entering into the payment field again it's blacked out
on there, but we can see how long that he's in there for,
right? He was in there just long enough to
enter in the credit card information and then
he exited out of it.
Now with our systems it automatically red
redacts the credit card information,
so there's no way for that employee to ever go back in
there and resee that credit card information.
So right there we knew.
The likelihood of him having written it down was very
slim to none. If he would have written it down, what we would
have seen is
We have heard in the call
where I blanked out for the credit card information.
But during that time, we would have seen, you know,
his screen not necessarily blanked out.
And then him going in and finally entering the credit
card information and going on from there. Like it wouldn't have
been a simultaneous thing if he was writing it down.
No, that's not to say that, you know, maybe he didn't, you
know, record it somehow or something like
that on his phone or something like a voice
recorder or whatever.
Very possible, but
unlikely.
So we're able to use that information.
The other piece that we actually use and we compared this to some
of our other information, we use the IP
address information.
So Termline gives us that information, tells us where somebody's
located at.
And we're able to look at it and say, OK.
Based on Termine's information plus our own internal
information. This
individual is located in this area.
Now the store that it was used at was 4
hours away.
Now, why you would drive 4 hours to go use a stolen
credit card, I don't know.
You might, right?
But not likely.
From there, what we also did is we said, OK,
we know that this is where he's located at.
The day that the card was used,
we went into her mind and looked down that specific day,
and that employee was working that day.
Called up Target. We got all the information.
Target confirmed that the card had been swiped.
They gave us a time stamp of when it was done.
And it was 2 hours before the employee shift.
No way that employee is swiping that card in,
and that target and then making it all the way back and on
time for a shift.
So we're actually able to take that information,
use the screen recordings from Terramine,
and
talk to the cardholder and say, hey,
our employee did not take your credit card
information. Again
Without the use of being able to see that, it would have been very
tough for us to be able to handle that situation.
Because then we're like one of those situations you kind of have to side
with that member, right? Like you don't really wanna
upset your member too much, so
potentially could have had to have like at least the very
least suspended this employee until we finished our
investigation by using this tool we were
actually able to resolve it same day.
I think once we did, I think we did it probably
about 2 hours
from the time that the member called to resolving
and then getting back on the phone with the member.
But like I said,
lots of positive use cases for this. I
honestly, I'd probably go on for days with all the different use
positive use cases that we can do from this.
But some of the other fun things that we've come across,
uh, from my side of it
is
just random weird things that I don't
even know why some of the employees would do this,
like fraudulent sick leave.
Like, we caught one person that
was
calling out sick,
but they were going into their computer, they were
purchasing their hotel
booking
on their computer so we could see them purchasing it for the
days that they called out sick.
So they're really just going on vacation.
But they didn't want to go through the proper steps of
requesting the time off and making sure that it was actually approved
and doing all that. They just said, you know what, I'm
going on vacation
and I'm just gonna do it.
So that was a, that was a fun one to do.
Uh, fake system issues.
So this is where from an IT perspective,
uh, Terramine gets really interesting as well, kind
of going back to some of those positive use cases,
uh, with the fake system issues.
Agents will call up and say, hey,
our telephones, my telephone system, it
crashed, and that's why, you know, I keep getting disconnected
from members and you know I'm having all these problems.
And we'll go in and we'll look at it and be like.
No, you hit the disconnect button
repeatedly on every single one of these customers, like you
had zero issues.
But on the flip side of that, we do, like I said, going
back to the positive use case,
we do allow our IT,
um,
employees to actually use this system as well to
help troubleshoot
some of these issues, right, if, if it's a legitimate
issue. Being in the IT world,
having to reproduce an issue.
It is difficult sometimes, right? Especially
when you're dealing with, you know,
either sales agents or people who aren't very tech savvy.
It gets kind of difficult because you're like, OK, I need
to know how to reproduce this. What were you doing
before, during, and after when this
issue occurred,
right? A lot of times they're like, I have no idea what I
was doing, but I just know that it crashed.
And sometimes it's, you know, a day or two later when they're
just like, oh yeah, by the way, I had this issue,
right? So as an IT person, you're like.
I have no way to reproduce this, and when I try
to do the steps that you told me, it's working
fine for me.
So with this tool, what they can actually go in
and do is now look at that individual and they can
say, oh,
here's what happened. Here's where everything was going on.
Here's the error message that popped up for you.
And better yet,
Terramine gives you the time stamp of
when it occurred. So now you can actually take that time stamp
and go back into your system logs
to get a better understanding on the back end of why this
error actually occurred to actually resolve it.
You know, with that, that's another way that you can also
build trust with the employees, right? Cause there's nothing
worse than when employees are reporting issues.
And
IT looks at it and says I can't reproduce this. I don't,
doesn't look like there's an issue,
and they keep reporting it and they keep getting no help.
So with this
now the IT folks are actually able to get in there and
fix these issues and which makes the employees
happy. The
Last one, manipulating time tracking.
So we had an individual
that was going through and
She would leave work early,
you know, sometimes 23 hours early,
go pick up her daughter from school or whatever
she needed to do, or go run her errands, get
back to her house.
When it was time for her to be off work,
she would then
clock out, you know,
via either her cell phone or some other
personal device, which we don't track those,
uh, so we have no idea to be able to say
for sure exactly what device she was using, but we know
it wasn't her work computer to clock out.
And then she'd also come in late,
but somehow she'd always be clocked in on time.
But then not show up for, you know, 1 hour or 2 hours
into the office.
So we started looking into it and what we started noticing
is.
She was just manipulating her time.
She would leave work early, sometimes she'd even
forget. And then she would reach out to her supervisor
and have her supervisor actually change her
time card for her.
So that way she would get paid for her full hours.
So again, without the use of, you know,
this type of tool like we would never would have really truly
caught that. It would have looked weird to us.
I mean go back and we could look at cameras and things like that
to start piecing it together,
but. Again, that would have
taken so much more time. This, this way we're able
to look at it very quickly.
Knock it out, have the discussion, correct the
behavior, and we be able to move
forward from there.
All right. And then lastly here.
You know, some of the, the, the key takeaways for
us. Um,
#1, behavioral analytics
are absolutely 100%
essential.
Understanding what your employees are doing,
how they're doing it, and why they're doing it
is just an absolute
essential need that every company should have.
Employee trust
This,
in my opinion, is probably the biggest one, right, from
a risk perspective.
The more trust that your employees have in your
company, the less likely they are to do something
that they shouldn't do.
It's Gonna help them,
you know. Number one, be better,
be more productive.
Like I said, mitigate that risk.
So building trust is key
to
and just in general, not even, you know, looking at it from a,
a perspective of like software monitoring or anything like that, just
in general building that trust with the employees is gonna be
key. Then lastly,
I guess this has been my favorite one since I do fraud and
I love fraud is a risk mitigation, right?
Having real-time data to actually
be able to
mitigate the risk,
right? Being able to move from a reactive
stance to a proactive stance.
Like that is a game changer.
Like I said, most of the time, fraud doesn't get
reported until months down the road.
If it even gets caught at all,
now we're in a point now where we can say
we can identify we've learned some of these behaviors, we
learned some of these patterns now we can build
out some of these
alerts and everything that we need to
to now move into a more proactive stance.
Now can we stop it, you know, prior to
like minority Report? No,
but we can get close, right? We can actually finally
catch this and, and be able to stop it
before any major harm is done.
And on that note,
any questions?